compacts are an important segment of the
automobile industry they are attractive
for both novice and experienced drivers
and also as a second car so it's not
surprising that the selection on the
market is large individuality is
becoming more and more important and
compacts so why not choose a car that
stands out from the masses like the Mito
from Italy our car tester on debate
Zimmerman says tradition Italian design
and passion have long been core values
for Alfa Romeo and this characteristic
radiator grille design is also the
brand's trademark
we're testing the meat so in the Junior
edition it's white 17-inch wheels and
mirror covers are eye catchers the jr.
logo on the rear is attractive too
inside the seats vary with the equipment
package the infotainment system has a
5-inch touchscreen Andre wishes he found
the passion and design of the exterior
in the interior as well but everything
is very dark and monochromatic he
doesn't think the radio is integrated
well either what he does like are the
instruments it looked very sporty and he
finds the Italian labels on them
charming our Mito with the basic engine
cost sixteen thousand six hundred euros
in Germany it gets a top speed of 165
kilometers an hour
this engine does without turbo charging
and generates only 57 kilowatts
Andriy says this test car doesn't
completely fulfill alfa romeos promise
of driving passion and top-notch
technology the basic gasoline engine is
not very powerful and that's also turned
Andres enjoyment down a notch the
suspension is suited for sporty driving
nice and stiff but the engine lags
behind Andre would prefer a smaller
steering wheel this one is more like
that of a van than of a sporty compact
it's not forties inclined fog none for
an additional 13 hundred euros you can
get the Mito with a 0.9 litre twin air
engine this turbocharged two cylinder
offers 72 kilowatts and adds 30 Newton
meters of torque to the basic engine and
the investment could pay off and save
fuel because the more expensive engine
is supposed to consume 1.4 liters less
gasoline per 100 kilometers
cut it under he gives us his overall
impression tradition Italian design and
passion they're all there in the
exterior and the suspension is very
sporty as long as you're willing to
invest a bit more in the engine you'll
end up with a chick little speedster
info and there soon clacking time with
Sun and